[Music]
when i first saw the bel-air trailer
a game wheel
look at you look at you i was on the
floor duh
for 20 years i've been trying to figure
out how to make the way back into the
world the only reason why you're not in
jail is because uncle phil called in a
favor
but the idea of shifting from sitcom to
drama while still staying in the same
lane of the ideas and the concepts
[Music]
who's this dude this dude's a genius get
him here immediately hey what's up y'all
it's morgan cooper executive producer
and pilot director of bel air
i was driving down 71 in kansas city the
idea hit me i went to a coffee shop and
wrote an outline for what i wanted to do
and we dropped it on youtube i met with
westbrook less than 48 hours from when
we dropped it he came down to the set of
bad boys three first time that i heard
something i was like yo that's that's an
idea
that
is brilliant morgan did a ridiculous
trailer
for
bel-air we just talked about the
potential of this show and what i saw is
that he got it he just expressed his
excitement about the idea and he's like
yo what do you want to do with it and i
told him what i want to do with he's
like i bet we have just officially
closed the deal
with peacock
with an unprecedented
two-season order from a pitch
[Music]
right away it was just the energy was
very very real i was born and raised in
kansas city growing up in the midwest
you didn't see wealth and opulence of
bel air you just didn't see those things
every single day he didn't see those
things at all he was a kid that grew up
on the ideas
of what will's experience was fresh
prince was always a part of our lives
and you know seeing will seeing these
iconic characters tell these stories at
a time where you didn't really see like
blackness portrayed in that way
[Music]
television is so collaborative that like
there are a lot of different opinions
when it came to selecting our writer's
room you know selecting the partners
involved and bringing this vision to
life the day i came across the trailer
we were working on another show
and it just looked like a great idea
that we wish we had thought of but i had
no expectation that we would be getting
on that show and then you sort of heard
news about it from afar i was like oh
they're doing that okay well that sounds
good and then our agent called us
and said they would like you to you know
consider joining the show
he was like oh this is this just became
very real very quick it was drinking
from a fire hose i would say it was a
very quick talk with morgan and malcolm
a very quick talk with executives at
westbrook and the next thing i knew we
were on the show
[Music]
i think the thing i've learned the most
and if i can go back in and talk to the
18 year old version of myself and lying
behind my first camera
is just to uh
to really believe in yourself and step
into the discomfort
[Music]
you